the number one thing that I want is
before my daughter says mommy or daddy I
want her to say trump trump supporters
have been called a lot of names like
racists crazy and dumb for beyond the
headlines more day when you look at the
demographics you see mostly white
working-class voters who are struggling
to get by and feel neglected by both
parties and there's no denying that
Trump is tapping into that he speaks
what's on people's minds who says
everything that I think they're the
types of voters you can find across
Pennsylvania which in recent years has
lost a lot of jobs and manufacturing and
coal mining so when Trump says I will be
the greatest jobs producing president
people here are listening jobs have gone
to Mexico and Sinai and for a lot of
people wedges have gone down Blas our
steel industry the blast now the coal
our energy you know that this whole area
we've lost jobs due to that and illegal
immigration
Tricia Cunningham is Regional Director
of Pennsylvania for Donald Trump and
possibly his biggest fan here's what it
sounds like when someone calls her
Nicholas I hear him all day long telling
me you to trust my instincts is s if I
do you love Donald try do and she's not
alone in feeling this way more than
90,000 Democrats in Pennsylvania
switched the registration to Republican
this year many to vote for you guessed
it I actually switched my affiliation
and independent to Republican
truck but the more I spoke to Trump
supporters the more I realized that
Trump to them is like a savior he's the
warrior he's taken it all on what about
some of his comments about women oh it
doesn't turn me off at all can he do any
wrong in your eyes very little he's the
guy that won my heart his heart and his
time
Brendan is 25 with a baby on the way and
is volunteering all his time with a
trump campaign it's pretty deep
this is like the wall of Trump you had
this shirt Donald Trump signed it and
said and gave you a name for your yep
doctor Missy gave me the name yeah then
he signed the shirt he said give it to
your daughter as a present for mr. Trump
to her and so when she's born you're
gonna name her what Donald Trump said
which is marry yep I got asked by a
newspaper so you're part of the silent
majority message no I'm not
what do you mean your Trump's purse is
yeah the reason why it's a silent is
prevent nobody listen to these
politicians are in the back pockets of
these lobbyists and nobody has come to
our rescue
and then a long promise mr. Trump
self-funding he's not in anybody's back
pocket
so you're saying that the reason you
have so much faith in him is cuz he's
not a politician
exactly
faith that what he's going to do is put
the right people in place and act like
to see yo I heard similar beliefs at a
trump rally in the Capitol Harrisburg
with thousands lined up for hours to see
their hero live in the flesh but there
was something else in the air too
and at times it was kind of scary